So, some of these events that
we've been talking about and
put in our list affect the different
concurrently executing
sub-machines that we've
already modelled.
See if you can figure out which ones
of these, which ones these are and
label the transitions in the finite
state machine with their numbers.
So, pick a particular event and decide
which of the state machines are affected
by that particular event happening.
>> Starting with number one for
turning the dial for the frequency,
that would be affecting our
station finance statement.
>> So, we would now expect, as a,
in that particular machine,
the station of machine that the arc
that we have, the self arc that we have
is going to be labelled by a particular
event, which is event number one, okay?
Simple, right?
And we can do the same thing for
some of these other events and
come up with an annotated diagram or
a diagram in which the transitions
all have arcs on them.
In our particular,
this particular exercise,
we don't have any
spontaneous transitions.
The spontaneous transition is
where you're in some state and
you go to the next state
without any event happening.
Okay, so we ultimately are going to see,
we're going to need to have for each
of the arcs that we have in the diagram,
some have been causing the transition.
Remember that our arrows with two heads
on them are really an abbreviation for
two arrows, one going in each direction.
>> So I think we meant event four for
the, event one I think's changing the
volume so that would be the volume dial
state machine but for
this one were talking about four.
>> Okay so with the transition
were putting on the station knob,
self transition is for event four.
Here are the additions to our machine
to handle events one, two, three, four,
12, and 13.
So with respect to event one,
that's the volume knob that's similar
to our station one, or
switching the band between AM and FM.
Those are events two and three,
one going to the left and
one going to the right.
And similarly sliding the mode switch to
the right and left are events 12 and 13.